stavo girando sul sito dove prende i
giochi di solito è noto questo ragazzo a
skate ace volume 1 vado a vedere il
prezzo se i dollari e 66 iniziamo bene
vediamo però dove andiamo a finire
siamo ritornati sui giochi quelli che
hanno la grafica in vhs e l'inquietudine
in questo tipo di stile videoludico mi
fa cacare sotto quindi a la copertina
giustamente game select addirittura
vorrei fare questo coi ragni mi piace lo
giuro allora c'è il bambino che dice ah
aiutarci papà io sono tuo figlio
e questa cosa succede mia moglie mi
proteggo io ci sono i ragni mi proteggo
io mangiate la mia famiglia non
toccatemi mangia la mia famiglia sta di
là potete ucciderli base vi fate uscire
come si esce
come si esce di qua tranquilli non c'è
nessun problema vostro padre vi aiuta
vostro padre guarda come servo le
finestre che è un piacere
mamma mia come si picchiano come li
dovrei picchiare questi cosi spiega il
martello non serva perché allora faccio
le armi in armi mammamia guarda che
grafica fasti ragni fanno rumore di di
porci ma non è normale amore ti proteggo
io non ti preoccupare ti vedo un po
triste oggi che succede ci penso io ci
penso io ragazzi tranquilli adesso ho
capito come menarli non ce n'è per
nessuno
meno bene lo meno lo è morto meno male
che sto gioco c'è una grafica pessima
solo mi farebbe veramente troppo schifo
vieni qui vieni classico non toccare la
mia famiglia non tocca la mia famiglia
ma bastava che è stato è uscito come
face recuperar vita
mannaggia
sono morto nuovo ice core però non ha
ancora una volta ragazzi cos'è sta roba
open cloud set plan and open e non
l'open porca vacca
dov'è che hanno sfondato non li vedo
eccolo mena yemen l'hero arrivo ragazzi
arrivo dove che siete non mi dicono che
si scende e non mi dicono che si scende
peccato sono morti da mia famiglia è
morta
eccovi ci sono tra l'altro la mia
famiglia è durata un'ora e mezza io sono
morto subito l'ultimo fatemi fare un
punteggio decente
sono morto ho fatto come prima ma vedo
che è una casa bellissima pronto tatiana
segue detto cose che c'era dietro anche
rosa c'è una vagina gigante fermi billy
idol da rendevo devo dar da mangiare a
sta roba veramente acqua ecco perché
siamo figli billi che io lancio le robe
lì dentro va bene datemi cose che le
devo dare alla mia pagina
mi scusi ma non può ballare mi nella tv
così che perché noi di sono questi
fronte dormi never leave this way
a me servono robe da daraa e la pistola
a van bull al treviso l'altro a colpi
infiniti questa fare immagine
[Applauso]
sparo talmente forte che il mio braccio
si allontana da me bellissimo no
sarà mai sfidare la vagina orca vacca
vista degli ottenendo top dovrei aver
lanciato la pistola teoricamente fate
sono oggetti a me torniamo ii e lanciava
altre cose dentro tipo la flashlight si
può prendere ok parcella questo non si
apre bello però i 6 euro e 66 meglio
spesi della mia vita se proprio volete
saperlo a questi lancia questo non lo
posso lanciare non posso lanciare a
flash non aveva la pistola sì però e
allora ci entro anch'io a noi non ci
posso proprio entrare qui dentro ok
peccato avrei voluto la pistola se le
mangia se mangiato tutto è stato un
piacere a si può guidare nita gun
ma come mi dougan rifacciamo qui riapro
allora la prima cosa è questa tieni così
il telefono è la prima cosa che ti
lancio so che ne farai buon uso
a prescindere da quello clown mask che
indossero subito ok è il revolver marca
baccano arrivato dallo lanciato per
terra non riescono a tenerlo in mano
entriamo si entra ecco qua adesso sì che
guidò il telefono ancora che suona in
tutto questo dove stiamo andando
o se è successo lì in salve qualcuno al
telefono secondo me si giochi quando
appena giocato in qualche modo si
incastrano l'uno con l'altro prima che
non ho idea di come gli degli altri come
si come funzionino
io devo farmi luce con la pistola perché
non vedo niente ce l'avevano flashlight
ma chissà dov'è finita salve buongiorno
[Applauso]
questo video è stato sponsorizzato da
prodotti family friendly per tutta la
famiglia ragazzi allora è mi deve dire
un secondo cosa stava facendo qua perché
non è che possiamo chiamare così ecco
questo telefono che sentivo da ore mi dà
fastidio
comunque io le rubo la macchina posso
posso ma lo sento ancora il suo telefono
gestore certo telefono che squilla che
mi dà un fastidio di continuo lo sento
ancora comunque torniamo indietro la
macchina e andiamo avanti perché la via
la vita continua insomma a questo nome
l'ho forzata
[Musica]
mi scusi la devo appoggiare e io che ne
sono me lo dicono
belle le braccia allora aspetti che la
prendo e la porto dove dove si dimettono
le persone come lei devo tornare alla
mia macchina ragazzi qua sotto al ramo
che splende allora lei non ha proprio la
bella cera l'apporto all'ospedale
signora mi scusi mi hanno fatto fare
questo a me che cosa devo fare
la carico sulla sul pick up eccolo ecco
con che fisica va bene guidiamo 20
una vita difficile sono tornati qua a
devo dar da mangiare alla vagina ho
capito bassa suo telefono butta lo tieni
a posto poi altro va bè ragazzi immagino
che il continuo sia che applica vende
mail bombe che continuo sia rispondere
al telefono proprio telefono se l'è
mangiato la vagina quindi non ce l'ho
più chiedevo concludere qua è stato un
bel video fatto di niente e cosi oggi il
mio canale è stato un po psichedelico
non saprei spiegarlo meglio però
simpatico allo stesso tempo non vedono
anche più il telefono tosse ingurgitato
e ancora mi chiede di rispondere non se
ci fosse possibilità roba prospera mesi
ha preceduto ragazzi e vabbè non si io
saprei che cosa dire dopo tutto sto
casino prova beh non dormite in casa e
così assicuratevi di pulire casa
quest'anno molto importante allora dico
io sono stati 6 euro e 66 peggio buttati
nella mia esistenza guarda come mi si
allontana al braccio ma non fa niente
come al solito semi dove è piaciuto ha
lasciato un bel mi piace rischio e
commentate qua sotto secondo voi che
cosa diavolo io appena giocato e come si
fanno a rimborsare dei dollari
chiedete a canale decidiamo come sempre
hanno fosse un video dai ragazzi
[Musica]
ma